sometimes Washington booby using it up
you also want to eat that listen that's
why there's movie recipes today we'll
with Chef Kevin Gillespie at revival in
Decatur Georgia we've challenged him
with making a dish the foodies of Middle
earth would enjoy he selected several
ingredients even the most discerning
hobbits would be happy they are
sausage and bacon variety because the
unprocessed landscapes of dizzyland are
what makes these movie so beautiful
mushroom caps because Lincoln may have
inadvertently the view to dream up an
alert and free bread because she's got a
carve up or journey demoted for furrow
[Music]
water rings massive trilogy here you
would truly a good trilogy unlike The
Hobbit that we have later yeah now we're
going to eat a meal that's inspired by
this movie yeah how many different
directions could this guy go
I don't know so many movies so many
ingredients you have limbus bread we've
got the potatoes you have a raw fish the
rabbit stew gratitude
[Music]
Oh
I would say that probably my favorite
scene is in the two tower and Sam
talking about he's basically going to
that big long speech while you see all
this stuff happening like the end coming
in and you know going to Saruman castle
and all these other things his speech at
the end is always like at the end giving
me chill bumps at the end of it and I'm
like I'm ready to see Return of the King
now yeah my favorite scene is the
lighting of the torches and the
mountains and the way the camera turns
and the music's were amazing yeah just
me every time with your face I think the
ghosts are oh I think that because right
before when they're you know want to
talk to him everything you have this
moment where everybody hesitated and
then Eragon just basically says I did
not fear death and he just charged right
and it's like inspiration well I think I
think it's true right he doesn't be the
point it was just like wow they know he
knows that he has to do this or else
always lost if I don't do this and I
could die but I'm gonna die anyway
[Music]
so we're all in agreement mm the best
one of the iteration yeah I I I know
that back in the day seemed like a lot
of people thought this was just a bridge
movie like it relied on the first one
and it relied on what happens after in
the third to be an effective movie I
disagree with that it's kind of like
what you're saying with Empire Strikes
Back and everything like that this is
this is where like most of the good
stuff that I remember from the trilogy
happens yeah who's gonna be to the
sandwich yeah where all the fun stuff
happens and everything and he is the
bread is great but you want to meet
Polly bread yes you gotta have bread and
meat to make it a sandwich otherwise
it's just me and the bottom half the
bread is what wins all the Academy only
[Music]
a second break second Vic this is
stick-to-your-ribs stuff right here yeah
you know it's funny they never really
like clarified what went in second
breakfast so I kind of went with the
classic English breakfast tradition and
there's there's that that tradition kind
of exists all over the all over the
world and so we just sort of mixed it up
and said you know what second breakfast
feels like it should be hearty so yeah
so we have a bunch of different stuff so
we have just a real basic grilled tomato
just over the fire a little salt and
pepper next to that we have something
called bribe bread that is kind of a
grilled cheese sandwich it's bread that
is just slathered in butter the inside
of it is covered in chutney like English
chutney and then it has sliced tomatoes
sliced onion and smoked cheddar cheese
and then that cooks over the grill we
have dry cured bacon so those the two
kind of thick slices we have a dry cured
smoked sausage we have some mushroom
caps fried in bacon fat beans cooked
over the open fire and then an egg fried
in all that residual fat from the
sausage and bacon and everything oh well
you went for hearty and you got this
whole plate smells like a campfire
exactly well that's it is that I was
like it in the movie you know they
stopped out obviously all of their
cooking is done over an open fire and so
it felt like we had to do that Wow so we
were a little worried you were going to
service lend us bread or what I should
have done I would have started baking it
last weekend so that it really set with
you for a long time so you know what now
we went back and forth on like what
exactly what a hobbit have for second
breakfast and so you know we chose a lot
of the dry-cured stuff because it seemed
like you could cope that around in your
backpack and then I just remember in
them in the movie them stealing
mushrooms from the farmers garden and so
I was like well surely they'll have the
mushrooms around like maybe they'll have
a tomato like some sort of the breads a
little bit of a stretch but
simultaneously it's not a real full fry
up if you don't have some greasy bread
component that I can assess 'ti and
obviously when you go camping like I
think of beans you know they're easy to
carry they're easy to cook over a
campfire so they made perfect sense so
what is your what is your favorite movie
of the trilogy and what is your favorite
scene out of Approval it's so tough I I
love all
three of them so much I think Return of
the King is my favorite of the three
god this story feels the most
well-rounded that seems to have the
right amount of climax and just and as
far as like favorite scene in the movies
right when you start into the two towers
with Gandalf fighting the Balrog as he's
sort of flying and dropping through the
center of the earth they go it's just
amazing I remember the first time I saw
that in the theater just being like this
is the coolest thing I've ever done like
because it was just so epic you know
it's such a it's such an amazing film
especially the first time seeing it on
the big screen in the theater the
magnitude of some of these shots you
know and then knowing after watching
interviews that you know some of those
backdrops are real like does that assume
that that's just New Zealand
you know aka middle-earth and yeah and
it makes you want to go why have I never
been there I'm like that's amazing yes I
don't want to stop eating all everything
I've faced it is amazing this is only
about 30,000 calories so it's fine if
you finish the whole thing yeah it
really fits into a six meal a day plan
it's like the Grand Slam on steroids
yeah exactly exactly this is the first
half of it I have the other half outside
I'll go get it now
[Laughter]
[Music]